>> THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN
MOMENT, IT'S A MORAL MOMENT IN
OUR COUNTRY.
ULTIMATELY, NOT WHETHER HE IS
INNOCENT OR GUILTY, THIS IS NOT
A TRIAL, BUT ULTIMATELY HAS
ENOUGH QUESTIONS BEING RAISED
THAT WE SHOULD NOT MOVE ONTO
ANOTHER CANDIDATE.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS
SENATOR SPARTACUS IN NEW JERSEY
SAYING AS YOU JUST HEARD, IT
DOESN'T REALLY MATTER IF BRETT
KAVANAUGH IS INNOCENT OR GUILTY.
DEMOCRATS SPENT SO LONG
ATTACKING HIM WITHOUT TANGIBLE
EVIDENCE THAT REALLY IS HIS
OBLIGATION TO JUST SUBMIT AND
LET HIS CAREER AND REPUTATION
AND FAMILY BE DESTROYED FOR THE
GOOD OF THE COUNTRY.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS A RETIRED LAW
PROFESSOR AND AUTHOR OF THE
BEST-SELLING "THE CASE AGAINST
IMPEACHING TRUMP."
DO YOU THINK, PROFESSOR, THAT
THAT'S A FINE STANDARD, IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF HE'S INNOCENT
OR GUILTY, HE SHOULD JUST
SUBMIT.
>> IT SOUNDS VERY FAMILIAR.
WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE THAT'S
WHAT THEY SAID ABOUT PEOPLE THAT
WERE ACCUSED OF BEING COMMUNIST.
AND IF YOU ANGRILY RESPONDED AND
SAID, YOU ARE NOT, THEN IT'S
JUST A JOB INTERVIEW AND WHAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE IF YOU ARE
INNOCENT OR GUILTY?
THIS GOES ALL THE WAY BACK TO
THE INQUISITION WHERE THEY WOULD
CALL YOU IN FIRST AND MAKE YOU
TESTIFY, AND THEN THEY WOULD
PRESENT THE EVIDENCE.
ONCE YOU ARE ACCUSED OF THE MOST
HEINOUS CRIME IMAGINABLE, IT
TURNS INTO A TRIAL WHERE YOU
HAVE DUE PROCESS.
WHERE THE BURDEN OF PROOF IS ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
WHERE THE EVIDENCE HAS TO BE
CLEAR AND CONVINCING.
IN AMERICA, WE DON'T ALLOW
PEOPLE TO DESTROY OTHER PEOPLES
REPUTATIONS AND CAREERS BASED
UPON INFERENCE OF GUILT, THE WAY
THE ACLU NOW SAYS.
THE ACLU SAYS WE SHOULD PRESUME
GUILT AND NOT INNOCENCE.
>> SO YOU ARE A LIBERAL AND YOU
HAVE LIVED YOUR LIFE IN A
LIBERAL WORLD.
DID ANY OF THEM EVER SAY, I
DON'T AGREE WITH KAVANAUGH, I
HATE TRUMP, BUT I AGREE WITH
YOU.
DUE PROCESS IS WORTH PRESERVING.
>> FOR EXAMPLE TODAY 700 LAW
PROFESSORS SIGNED A LETTER.
AND I REFUSED TO SIGN IT.
SAYING HE NOW NO LONGER HAS
JUDICIAL TEMPERAMENT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THIS WERE A
LIBERAL WHO HAD BEEN APPOINTED
BY A LIBERAL PRESIDENT WHO HAD
BEEN A KEY AND ACTED SIMILARLY?
I DON'T THINK ANY OF THEM WERE
PROFESSORS.
SENATOR BOOKER WHO I LIKE AND
KNOW WAS JUST DEAD WRONG, IT WAS
ALL ABOUT PARTISANSHIP.
IF IT WAS THE DEMOCRATS WHO
OPENED UP THAT CANDIDATE,
EVERYONE WOULD BE BEHAVING THE
OPPOSITE WAY.
AND, WE DEFENDED OUT AL FRANKEN
ON THE SHOW, WHOM I DON'T LIKE
PERSONALLY AND I HATE HIS
POLITICS BUT I THINK YOU GOT
SHAFTED FOR THE SAME REASON.
>> AND HE WAS DEFENDED, TOO.
>> HE DESERVE TO BE DEFENDED.
YOU WERE QUOTED IN A RECENT
PIECE SAYING THAT JULIE
SWETNICK'S LAWYER HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WITHDRAW HIS
STATEMENT.
>> THERE ARE ETHICAL AND BAR
RULES THAT SAY WHEN YOU SEND AN
AFFIDAVIT EVEN TO CONGRESS AND
HE LATER LEARNED THAT THERE ARE
THINGS IN THE AFFIDAVIT THAT ARE
FALSE, YOU HAVE A CONTINUING
OBLIGATION TO WITHDRAW THE
AFFIDAVIT.
YOU CANNOT ALLOW AN AFFIDAVIT TO
REMAIN ON THE RECORD, IF YOU
HAVE INFORMATION SUGGESTING ITS
CAUSE.
IN ANY REASONABLE LAWYER, SAYS
YOU CAN'T ANY LONGER ACCEPT
WHAT'S IN THAT AFFIDAVIT.
SHE HAS TO BE INVESTIGATED
INDEPENDENTLY OF THE BACKGROUND
CHECK, CRIMINALLY INVESTIGATED,
TO SEE IF SHE DELIBERATELY AND
WILLFULLY, WITH OR WITHOUT THE
AID OF ANYONE ELSE MADE A
DECISION JUST TO FRAME SOMEBODY
FOR SOMETHING HE HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH.
THE EVIDENCE SEEMS TO SUGGEST
THAT THEY NEVER KNEW EACH OTHER,
THEY WERE YEARS APART AND
OPERATING IN DIFFERENT CIRCLES
AND IT WOULDN'T SURPRISE ME IF
THE FBI INVESTIGATION AND PROVED
THAT THEY NEVER MET EACH OTHER.
IF THAT TURNS OUT TO BE FACT,
SHE BELONGS IN THE COURT OF LAW,
BEING PROSECUTED WITH THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AND A
DEFENDER.
BUT IF THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
SHE COMMITTED PERJURY, PRISON.
>> Tucker: WHILE.
>> YOU KNOW WHY?
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO PROTECT
PEOPLE AGAINST BEING, BUT ALSO
PROTECT THEM FROM BEING
WILLFULLY AND FALSELY ACCUSED OF
RATE.
IT'S A VERY SERIOUS CRIME, AND
WE HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION TO